does anyone believe that tech platforms
are impartial anymore
i don't see how you could i don't think
they make any pretense to impartiality
anymore either
especially when the partiality is baked
into the terms and conditions
uh twitter being the best example of you
can't misgender someone it's like
sorry there is only one ideology
probably in all of human history that
has made a big deal about gender
identity and
uh you know gender expression in the way
that
the the left is now we all know what
ideology this is in sectionality
and it's very obvious that this is uh
therefore an intersectional domain
if you can actually lose your account i
mean like i've had friends who have been
suspended for calling people
dude which i consider to be a fairly
gender-neutral
you know in an informal gender-neutral
way of referring to a person
and it's it's also um sort of part of
a uh how to describe it like a sort of
informal social
pattern of behavior where you if you
call someone dude you realize that you
you're setting the context for the
interaction it's like you know if i say
hey mate you know
i don't expect you to call me sir i'll
be formal or say you know mr this
whatever
and you you realize that we're having a
friendly conversation that has good will
behind it you know
it implies a kind of good will when i
enter into the conversation
and so like if in in
in my world in the in the social spheres
i exist in
um calling someone dude isn't me saying
you're a man
whereas in the sort of i guess san
francisco californian left-wing view of
things
actually oh my goodness you've just
misgendered this is a high crime against
twitter's terms of service you must be
banned
it's always the worst possible
implication like the worst possible
way the interpretation interpretation
sorry
there that there definitely is an
element of that
um but i i also think there's a kind of
dogmatic view of certain words
like um the f word right that we can't
say anymore uh now i i grew up watching
south park
and from watching south park i actually
had not connected
really that word to homosexuality i
connected that word to
a kind of um insufferable childish
behavior
which is not in my opinion limited to
people who are gay and so i
didn't consider it to be a particularly
bad word but it's
now been i guess reclaimed by the lgbt
lobby the sort of activist lobby and
stigmatized so now that word is actually
a very bad word that's
the equivalent of like the n-word and
things like this oh god now we've we've
actually
you know from a word being actually
relatively benign and
you know not trivial has become
something again you can get
banned or suspended for from these
platforms it's like wow that's that's
interesting weaponizing
words that had otherwise lost their
power i would have thought was the
opposite of the direction that the
progressives would want to go in
but i suppose it does give them a useful
tool with which to sort of browbeat and
harry the uh the wrong thinkers so
i've been trying to think about why
social media always seems to throttle
people like stephen crowder like right
instead of left
and i get it that like in the eyes of
big corporations that the left-wing's
associated with
compassion and virtue and the rights
associated with intolerance and bigotry
even if that may sometimes seem like
it's actually being flipped on his head
but i can't work out if that explains it
all like is there an element that
because conservatives
especially in america they tend to play
quite fast and loose with claims
in a way which is more easily disputed
so the crazier claims of the left
seem to be more esoteric and
unfalsifiable whereas the crazier claims
of the right seem to be at least rooted
in reality
even if they're unhinged do we can we
can we think of an example of each of
those just so
uh so when we're talking about semantic
overload when people are playing around
with what words mean
with all lives matter versus black lives
matter for instance
um but for people on the right if
it would be to do with um
perhaps the way that uh
workers are being moved out of jobs
about stats to do with immigration
they may be inflated and they may be
wrongly cited
but at least they're falsifiable yes
um okay yeah the yeah the one so the way
the the way that i think about it um and
from the way you've just laid that out
um is the fact that the left
the academic left at the moment seems to
be essentially rooted in semantics games
the redefinition of words in fact and
the rights in my experience
and i'm not saying this is exclusive or
anything actually tends to just use the
common english language
definitions of words and this is this is
why it's actually quite a pleasure to
read someone like thomas sowell right
because he just lays out he never has to
redefine a word because he just uses it
in the common english parlance
because he's not trying to be a
pretentious academic about it he's
trying to just lay out look this is the
data
this is my interpretation of said data
in a common sense straightforward manner
uh do you find this persuasive and it
turns out that actually millions of
people find this
find this persuasive whereas the left
have to come up with very as you said
esoteric
ways of looking at things and actually
well let me tell you what the real
definition of a woman is let me tell you
what the real definition of patriarchy
is let me tell you about the real and
it's what hang on a second
you know i didn't agree to any of these
real real definite redefinitions
and i don't agree to the definition you
finally come out with
um the classic example being of course
the definition of a woman
for uh for a right winger i guess uh
which means essentially just
someone who isn't politicized into the
culture war
a woman in the dictionary is an adult
human female which is
a good and sensible definition it's got
particular limits it has essential
characteristics
and it's not self-referential so you're
not uh going around in a circle when
you're trying to define it so it makes
sense
you don't need to actually think about
that any any further really and that's
probably why it's the basic definition
whereas the left version is a woman is
anyone who identifies as a woman
which is actually a really concerning
definition isn't it because
you realize we're hanging a second a you
haven't defined the word a woman is
anyone who identifies as
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is anyone identified
and so you've got this recurring loop in
the definition of the word and so the
sentence is never actually completed so
we don't have a definition there anyway
obviously being self-referential it
gives us no information
on what a woman actually is other than
some kind of being
that identifies as this empty
word this this word that has yet to be
given any content
um and also the weird thing about it and
i've been thinking about this a lot
because like
what the the the important thing about
definitions is also
what's excluded from the definition not
just what's included
because if you take out the term adult
from the definition of woman
then what you're saying is that
non-adults
and maybe even non-humans uh if you take
out the the human part could identify as
women
and that's really weird isn't it because
i've actually had a child
come up to me when i was doing my
southwest uh mep tour um
i actually had like a 12 year old girl
come up to me and say something like
i'm a woman uh you know don't oppress me
i'm you know because i'm a feminist or
something
and it was really weird because it's
like look you're actually not a woman
you know you're a child
you're not a woman so why has this child
decided that they can come up to me and
act like they're some sort of
moral authority on the subject of what
being a woman is
says they haven't got to the stage in
life that is womanhood anyway
um and the implications of like you know
taking out
the the requirement of that being an
adult is actually
kind of worrying and probably something
that should be put back in so i mean
even
even if you were going to be an
insectionalist about it you'd be like
okay a woman is any adult who identifies
as a woman would be a perfectly
acceptable
no it wouldn't be acceptable but it
would be a better step up than just
having it as
completely open you know because i mean
well it opens up the possibility if we
could somehow
show that this pig identified as a woman
would we be justified in treating it as
a woman you know
and how would we justify not treating it
as a woman you know
so it obviously i don't think that we'll
be able to show that but the
possibilities are strange and silly
and it's because we've moved away from
the essential characteristics
and uh i think that you end up in this
sort of
this kind of hollow world because there
was a a un women's
uh conference uh upon which this some
uh a disabled black speaker woman uh
lady female i i mean i i don't know how
i'm supposed to characterize her but
uh she said that a woman is something
like it was something like
shapeless and formless and timeless and
eternal it's like this is sounding like
an elder god
from cthulhu like a shapeless
formless timeless entity it's like what
what the hell is the use of the term
woman anymore you know why would anyone
want to transition to become a woman or
identify as a woman
if there's no form or shape or
definition to it what was the point of
this
yeah you know and so this this gives
strength to the turf argument that
actually they're trying to obliterate
the term woman and this will damage
women's rights because obviously if you
can't define what a woman is and
identify a woman from
anything else how can you have women's
rights and they've got a point
so that's a very slippery game playing
around with semantics and semantic
overload and i think that what crowder
does when he does make his arguments his
arguments are at least rooted in things
that can be falsified and that people
can complain about yes whereas with that
it's always just a game of trying to
catch this incredibly slippery eel
and as soon as you get anywhere close to
it it changes form into
smoke and cthulhu and pisses off
that that's exactly how i feel about it
and that's that's why
unfortunately a lot of modern discourse
has come down to games of semantics
which is actually terribly tiresome if
you think about it because it doesn't
advance anything
it ends up meaning you get kind of
bogged down in incredibly pedantic
conversations but unfortunately i guess
that if this is the
the current ideological and
philosophical trend that swept the west
we've got to engage with it as it is
right
[Music]